thanks very much to Samantha now the UK
would face economic rupture if it leaves
the European Union that's according to
the new Work and Pensions Secretary
Steven Crabb meanwhile former Irish
prime minister as you may just have seen
Bertie Ahern as war leaving the EU would
be regressive and negative in every way
for Britain and Ireland while I'm joined
now by Theresa Villiers the Northern
Ireland secretary she's one of the
government ministers for backing the
vote leave campaign in a very good
morning to your Secretary of State let's
just him first of all that's a warning
from your colleague Stephen Crabb about
how reckless and economically damaging
it could be for Britain to leave the
European Union well I'm afraid that's in
stark contrast to what the Prime
Minister has been saying for many weeks
that of course we can be a success
outside the European Union I think we
would flourish because we'd get back the
right to run our own trade policy that
means being able to make deals with
crucially important economies like the
u.s. like China like India deals which
the EU has had decades to deliver and so
far hasn't that's good for jobs whereas
staying in means inevitably we face the
EU asking for more power and more money
year after year that's the real risk
that's the thing that's bad for jobs
interest but it is just matters of
opinion really isn't it I mean we've had
the IMF no less warning about on the
danger side and there's no doubt for
instance that things like sterling the
pound would take a hit in the immediate
aftermath of a brexit vote that would
have an economic effect well I'm afraid
the IMF has got things seriously wrong
in the past and when the chairman of the
Bank of England was asked about risks to
the UK economy in Parliament recently he
was very clear that it's the external
risk particularly in relation to China
which are the significant ones rather
than the domestic ones I mean you know
we're good to hear from the Treasury the
government assessments on the on the
economic side apparently tomorrow which
is going to describe possible recession
hit - exports rising prices jobs at risk
I mean you put you in a difficult
position doesn't you have to disagree
with your own Treasury well the fact
that we all have effectively a free vote
on this does lead to awkward situations
but the government has made it clear
that is not a neutral bystander so
people will judge the statements of the
Treasury on that basis
the the crucial thing is that we have
the opportunity to vote to restore our
democracy to go back to a position where
the people we elect at a general
election or a devolved election are the
people who are making our lives but you
think it is a misuse of the government's
powers and we're thinking particularly
about this leaflets that that has been
delivered to almost every doorstep in
the United Kingdom the 9.3 million
pounds
spent on that well obviously it makes
the campaign one-sided the the
establishment inevitably lines up in
these debates in favor of the position
but if you look back these are the sort
of people who are saying it was
essential that we join the erm these are
the sort of people who predicted doom if
we kept her own currency the Chancellor
worked he had their backing the leaflet
and presumably backing the Treasury
certainly many people within the
establishment within the remain campaign
people like Peter Mandelson for exactly
the sort of people who said that it was
vitally important that we join the euro
and if we didn't you know jobs would be
lost in wood investment would disappear
overnight
and universally all the experts say that
we would never have been able to recover
from the economic shock of the financial
crisis as strongly or as quickly if we
join the euro so are you I mean we heard
this almost before the formal campaign
got underway are you being denied as a
cabinet minister use of civil servants
access to documents if you want to use
that information and those resources to
further the vote leave campaign well
obviously I don't have access to
resources to further the vote leave
campaign from the government but I can
reassure you that I see all the papers
and documents that I need to carry my
role the Secretary of State for Northern
Ireland but it's just that on that you
described to there the suspension on
this issue of collective responsibility
you obviously think was wise of the
prime minister to allow that to happen
but if he hadn't would you have resigned
I think to be honest I would have had to
but I am very very much welcome the fact
that I didn't face that choice but you
were prepared to take that step and did
you make the Prime Minister aware before
he made the decision
and I didn't have to because I went I
had several conversations with him I'm
sort of explained that this was a
long-standing issue of concern for me
and I really did feel that I had to be
on the leave side of the debate and he
explained that he wanted his cabinet to
be able to express their views obviously
he would very much have liked me to be
on the other side but he did make it
clear that he would allow cabinet
ministers for their conferences on this
issue so the issue of resignation never
never had to be discussed okay and the
issue of resignation I mean what do you
make of that from where Ken Clark the
other day that if your view prevails if
the brexit side when the Prime Minister
wouldn't last 30 seconds I completely
disagree with Ken on this issue and some
others I think the Prime Minister's
position should be absolutely secure
it's vitally important that he stays
regardless of the vote not a friendly
because he's a great Prime Minister but
should he be the one then that
negotiates the the brexit deal everyone
on all sides of the campaign knows how
complex that's going to be I mean its
heart wouldn't really be in it would
absolutely he should be the one that
leads our negotiations on the on the
brexit deal I think those negotiations
will go well the reality is that the EU
so that's far more to us than we do to
them it's in their interest to make sure
we have retain a strong trading
relationship a free trade deal what
David Davis your colleague in there in
this set campaign has been saying well
the Prime Minister shouldn't be the one
in you in the event of a black sapote to
negotiate that deal he should recuse
himself from that let's somebody from
the leave side a senior figure perhaps
yourself a senior figure from the
cabinet negotiate the deals I believe
absolutely the David Cameron is the
right man to take us out of the European
Union and negotiate the excellent deal I
think that we will get and stay on as
Prime Minister separately yes let's say
move to your own brief because there's
an awful lot of questions coming from
the people of the north of Ireland the
people in the Republic of Ireland and
indeed the people in the whole of the UK
about what would happen in the event of
a brexit to that border the only land
board of the United Kingdom has with the
European Union
three would it have to be would it have
to become more secure
I don't believe arrangements need to
change I think the land border we share
with Ireland can be as free-flowing
after a brexit vote as it is today
no special status for Irish citizen and
a common travel area allowing free
movement for our citizens predates our
membership of the EU by decades and
there's no reason why it can't continue
in the same way after we leave the EU
but we therefore in the United Kingdom
are reliant upon the Irish Republic
carrying out stringent border checks on
people who with the right of travel
within the EU at remaining of course
within the European Union that they
carry out those checks because once
they're in Ireland in the south of
Ireland they can travel to any part of
the UK without being checked well of
course it's important it will be
important after a brexit as it is
important now that the external borders
in the common travel area are properly
policed but those risks are managed
effectively today and they would be in
the future and remember if we had no
individuals who came in through the land
border who weren't entitled to enter the
UK we have internal mechanisms to deal
with that form of illegal immigration
you know controlling our borders doesn't
necessarily mean reinstituting borders
where are the internal mechanisms
they're not as you've just said they're
not on the border with the Irish
Republic are they then on Great Britain
now they are strong the measures we have
to deal with illegal working illegal
immigration access to housing these kind
of mechanisms which apply whether it's
in Northern Ireland or the whole of the
United Kingdom to ensure that people in
this country have the right to be here
so you don't need border checks or
checks between the northern our Northern
Ireland and Great Britain to make this
system work you can have a border which
operates broad is it so knowledge a
Lawson no I'm speaking last week and
Dominic Rab indeed another member of the
of the brexit campaign of the leave
campaign both saying on different
programmes last week both saying that
there would need to be some kind of
checks because this is a backdoor Nigel
Lawson said Lord Lawson said that some
kind of border controls coming in well I
mean I think the leave campaign has
since sought to correct that I I think
was misunderstood the reality is it's in
everyone's interest that we maintain the
current arrangements in relation to the
border and the Irish ambassador in
giving evidence to MPs recently in
Parliament made it very clear that you
know the Irish government would have
that same goal in mind to ensure that we
continue to have free flow of goods and
people across that no cheques at all
just just to be absolutely explicit
second state no checks at all on the
Northern Irish border with the Republic
of Ireland yes that's right we don't
need to institute border checks if we
have a brexit vote and you would have no
security concerns then there may be
people who are granted refugee status
within the Republic of Ireland or being
considered for asylum who would not be
allowed into the UK but they are then
free to travel either to the to the
north of Ireland across that on police
border or under the free travel
arrangements to Great Britain itself
without any further checks well there
would be risk to be managed so as I say
we've got a range of measures to combat
illegal immigration which we could use
to manage that risk and these are the
checks that are in place at the moment
they're the sort of things you know
obligations are landlord obligations on
employers to ensure that they're not
giving homes to illegal migrants that
they're not employing illegal migrants
these kinds of measures to combat
illegal immigration are ones that we
could use in the events of a UK exit
just as we can so your response to
Bertie Ahern and indeed as you said
you've heard from so many figures with
in the the Irish political side and so
many other sides your response - Bertie
Ernie's you're wrong it's reassurance
there is no reason why we have to change
our border arrangements in the event of
a brexit because they've been broadly
consistent in the hundred years since
the creation of Ireland as a separate
state and actually you know I think
again the Irish ambassador in his
evidence Department made it clear that
it would be in Ireland's interest to
maintain these kind of arrangements in
it's in the interest of both countries
to keep an open border and so there's no
reason why that should change if the
people of this country decide to
exercise their freedom to vote to leave
the EU what about the future of the Good
Friday Agreement itself will know how
tortuous the process was to to get
negotiated and to keep the peace process
on track know within it runs like a
thread through the Good Friday Agreement
that both states are members of the
European Union wouldn't it all unravel
no I don't believe it would and actually
not not many people have made that
allegation just one or two figures from
the remain campaign and I think that's
scare mongering of the most
irresponsible and even dangerous kind
because what they're effectively saying
is that a vote to leave the EU would
somehow weaken the commitment of people
in Northern Ireland to peace and
democracy we can their commitment to
their future being determined by
democracy and consent I don't believe
that's going to happen the Belfast Good
Friday Agreement was endorsed in
referendums on both sides of the border
there is strong support for an entirely
peaceful future for Northern Ireland I
think it's deeply irresponsible I think
in the main camp to suggest that but
what about just on the pure legalities
this is an agreement between two states
that has clauses that refer to being
partners within the European Union one
party given your view it would not be a
member of the European Union doesn't
that have to be renegotiated I think
it's what what situation would be is we
would be facing the democratic exercise
of choice by the people of the United
Kingdom to leave the European Union I
think that's entirely consistent with
the Belle France Good Friday Agreement
and it would be in the interest of both
the UK and Ireland to continue with the
friendly relations that have been built
up you know the relationship between the
UK and Ireland has transformed over the
last 10 to 15 years and that is to do
too many factors and I believe that is
sufficiently strong that that would
survive a UK exit from the European
Union
just last question are you confident
that you could extract for Northern
Ireland the same level of agricultural
subsidy from a sovereign British
Parliament as it currently gets now from
the Common Agricultural Policy yes
certainly I think you know developed
countries all around the world recognize
that it's vital
you have generous farm support payments
all the main parties capable forming a
government in this country support
subsidies for our farmers they would
continue I think they would continue it
at least the same levels as they do
today and actually farmers in Northern
Iowa would be free of the you know
painful and exasperating bureaucracy
that comes with us EAP